rapport assez alarmant de l'onu
concernant le sort des enfants lors des
conflits armés on nous dit que 2018 a
été tristement marqué par un taux record
d'enfants qui ont été blessées ou tuées
lors de violations graves des droits des
enfants
il ya le secrétaire général
de l'onu qui a qualifié donc justement
ce rapport-là d'alarmant d'une
croissance alarmante on va en parler
avec jean nicolas bézy les représentants
du haut commissariat de l'onu
il a travaillé sur la question des
enfants en situation de conflit armé
bonjour monsieur buzz
bonjour vers l'est on parle de 12 mais
l'enfant qui ont été tués ou blessés en
2018 en raison de conflits armés comment
c'est possible comment on en est arrivé
à cette situation lost assez alarmant
alors effectivement c'est très alarmant
on voit de plus en plus que les conflits
perdurent
la communauté internationale a de plus
en plus de mal à restaurer la paix et
les enfants les civils en général les
femmes les adultes aux signes en
particulier les enfants sont pris entre
les feux des différents combattants sont
parfois enrôlés de force dans les forces
armées régulières ou dans les rangs de
l'armée rebelle souvent sous sont soumis
à des violences sexuelles plus de 7000
enfants
un mille enfants auraient été soumis à
des violences sexuelles dans ces
conflits armés mais ce qu'il faut
rappeler que ces chiffres ne sont que le
que la pointe de l'iceberg
ah il est très difficile pour les
parents pour les enfants de témoigner
pour nous les nations unies de nous
rendre sur place pour recevoir les
témoignages
mais qu'est ce qui se fait en ce moment
pour aider ces enfants là à qui la
responsabilité comment on leur vient en
aide
bon je vous pose beaucoup de questions à
la fois c'est une question très
troublant de se rendre compte que tant
d'enfants ne sont pas protégés qu'on
n'arrive pas à protéger des petites
filles où on en parle rarement mais des
petits garçons d'être violée dans le cas
de conflit armé ou qu'on les empêche
d'aller à l'école ou coûts n'ont pas
accès aux soins parce que les hôpitaux
sont devenus parfois des cibles ou
parfois les enfants sont recrutés et des
écoles elle même c
c'est quelque chose de très perturbant
ce qui est important de rappeler c'est
que la responsabilité première reste
avec les parties
au conflit les groupes mais c'est pour
ça que ce rapport est important parce
qu'il leur signale que le monde est en
train de les regarder et que les crimes
leurs crimes ne resteront pas impunis
malgré tout cette épée de damoclès de la
justice mais n'est pas aussi efficace
que l'on espère puisqu'on voit les
chiffres augmentent et le rapport le 10
et donc il faut trouver d'autres
solutions pour s'assurer que les enfants
et les autres civils soit en tout temps
protéger contre les effets de la guerre
dans quelles sont ses autres solutions
alors bien sûr il faut adresser les
causes profondes des conflits à les
conflits perdurent à cause de
compétition sur les ressources
naturelles à cause de problèmes
ethniques religieux qui ont été mal
gérées donc il faut vraiment faire appel
à la communauté internationale est ici
le canada peut jouer un rôle particulier
pour qu'on ramène les gens autour des
tables de négociation il faut aussi
adresser les questions de pauvreté et
les questions d'inégalité entre les gens
entre les groupes ethniques et ça ça
demande l'investissement dans le
développement dans l'humanitaire de
nouveau le canada peut jouer un rôle
particulier en donnant des financements
pour être sûr que les pays soient
stabilisés et puis il faut aussi prendre
action en termes de justice mais aussi
de réparation pour ses victimes et donc
continuer à donner de l'argent à des
organisations comme l'unicef où le hac
sert mon organisation pour être sûr
qu'on puisse apporter un soutien à ses
enfants
les protéger contre le recrutement forcé
ou les aider lorsqu'ils sont victimes de
de violence donc c'est sûr que
effectivement du soutien financier est
le bienvenu dans ce genre de situation
là mais vous y avez fait brièvement
allusion est ce qu'on est en mesure de
se rendre sur le terrain est d'aider ces
enfants là l'accès au terrain il est
difficile alors on le voit sans arrêt en
syrie on a des parties du pays qui sont
trop dangereuses pour nos équipes les
équipes des ong les organisations non
gouvernementales pour se rendre sur
place et porter secours à ces
populations
on peut multiplier sa avec la somalie le
yémen l'afghanistan mais aussi en
afrique du sud soudan ou même beaucoup à
les régions qui sont au nigeria à l'est
du nigeria dans les mains de boko haram
donc c'est là où on a besoin aussi de
l'appui de gouvernement tel que le
canada de rappeler aux parties aux
conflits et aux états qui les aident
derrière en leur fournissant des usa ou
en ordonnant une certaine appui politico
financier en lan rappelons que l'accès
humanitaire et absolue qui est
absolument primordial si on veut faire
la différence pour pour ses enfants 2018
donc à marquer
difficile utiliser le mourre record
lorsque l'on parle du sort des enfants
malheureusement ce n'est pas un mot que
l'on aimerait utiliser mais force est de
constater en voyant ces statistiques le
conte a enregistré des taux alarmants
des taux records est ce qu'on pense être
en mesure de renverser la situation
alors on a toujours on a toujours espoir
sinon mes collègues et moi-même
quitterions no no no no travail
je crois qu'il ya toujours espoir parce
qu'on voit quand même des progrès sur
certaines questions exemple accès à
l'école a été restauré dans un certain
nombre de pays en conflits en afrique
subsaharienne
on arrive parfois avoir des éclaircies
dans l'accès aux soins de santé
spécialisés pour les blessures de guerre
dans certains dans certains pays en
syrie on est en train de restaurer une
capacité pour les médecins de venir en
aide à ces enfants qui ont été blessées
en particulier par des mines où on en
afrique on ne voyait beaucoup d'enfants
qui avaient été mutilés avec des
machettes
donc il ya toujours espoir mais c'est
vrai que là la question même le
secrétaire général a rappelé la question
même au coeur de ces deux sets de ce
sujet c'est vraiment restaurer la paix
mettre fin au conflit
et là c'est vrai qu'on voit qu'il ya de
plus en plus de conflits à travers le
monde étaient ces conflits durs de plus
en plus longtemps et sont de plus en
plus complexe avec plusieurs parties au
conflit des groupes terroristes qui s'y
mêlent et ça devient très très compliqué
ils ce sont les plus vulnérables qui en
souffrent en bout de les jours
jean-nicolas buzz représentant du haut
commissariat de l'onu vous avez
travaillé donc sur le sort des enfants
dans plusieurs conflits armés on vous
remercie beaucoup de vous être déplacés
ce matin merci à vous